[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The Google Play Developer
Console app, launched last May,
helps you stay informed
of crucial business
updates on the go.
Take a look at the article
linked below for the latest
updates, including review
notifications, review
filters, staged rollout
control, and more.
Hole19 is a golfing app which
assists golfers before, during,
and after their golfing
journey with GPS
and a digital scorecard.
They've got close to 1 million
users across all platforms.
Watch the video to learn how
they doubled their Android Wear
users in six months and
improved user engagement
and retention on the platform.
To help bring virtual
objects to life,
we've updated the
Tango Unity SDK
to enable you to add
environmental lighting
to your Tango apps.
Take a look at the
article to get started.
Learn a few ways to
urge people towards
positive social experiences
in virtual reality
with this latest article
from Daydream Labs.
Version 1.7 of the Go
programming language
is now available.
And the release includes
compiler improvements,
the addition of the
context package,
and support for hierarchical
tests and benchmarks.
You can now deploy Python
3 apps on Google App Engine
with the beta release
of the Python runtime
on App Engine
flexible environment
with support for
Python 3.4 and 2.7.
For more details, a
video, and links to code,
check out the post.
Oh, and in the things
just got better column,
we've lowered the price of
preemptable VMs by up to 33%.
Details, including how to launch
a preemptable VM right now,
are on the post.
Don't forget to subscribe,
like, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next time.